well brian if there is one thing that
vegas does well
it is entertainment bars clubs shows
casinos are just a few ways that we come
out on top
but a new trend is taking hold secret
speakeasies
sasha loftis gives us a look inside this
exciting and secluded world
[Music]
bright lights spectacular sights and
endless entertainment they're all
staples of the city we know
and love but what else lies behind
closed doors
much more than you'd ever imagine
welcome to the world of secret las vegas
speakeasies
a lot of these secret rooms and back
rooms are popping up in vegas
all over the world these back door bars
pack a serious punch
but you have to earn your spot inside we
get the secret bookcase that you get to
go through if you can find us
1923 prohibition bar is tucked inside
mandalay bay
making its mark with bourbon bruise and
a touch
of tradition
[Music]
owner noel bauman says this vibe is all
the rage
as vegas roars back to life this is
really like the 1920s when prohibition
ended and vegas is really experiencing
that this demand
i can imagine in the 20s when it when
prohibition the real deal ended
you know it was gangbusters but the real
appeal lies
in its intrigue and effort to stay
unseen
it's got all these nooks and crannies
and little hidden areas
that you've got to go discover another
well-kept secret here in vegas is
downtown
at the commonwealth bar through these
doors you wouldn't expect it
but you walk inside a speak easy welcome
to
the laundry room it is a secluded place
it is hidden away
you have to be looking for it in the
first place this surreptitious spot
may be attached to a bustling bar but
lead barman anthony partridge says
its main perk is privacy there are no
picture takings in here no phone calls
no videos and so on so we try to keep it
secret amongst the persons you bring in
the laundry room
seats 20 people and runs strictly on
reservations once they step
into the room you can see them just kind
of like take it all in it's a classic
slice of old-fashioned charm
with an added character of custom drinks
i just need to hear a collection of
flavors you happen to appreciate and
me my mixologist will somehow figure out
the perfect drink for you out of
everything that you say
so if you're looking for a unique take
on valley nightlife
now's your chance to take part in this
modern taste
of timeless mystery these private groups
that are now coming back
are just clamoring for this type of
experience sasha loftis
8 news now
[Music]
the 1923 prohibition bar also has an
extra secluded room we were able to see
it but
couldn't disclose its location we do
have tips to snag your spot inside
though
on our website at 8newsnow.com